i had to be the example because my
daughter didn't have the father example
of a man so i had to step up and be that
power example of a woman
and to encourage my daughters that
nothing
don't allow nothing or anything stop you
[Music]
hello everybody can you believe it i'm
still right here that's right on the
south side of chicago living in this
tent for 100 days from november 20th to
february 28th bringing awareness about
the violence in chicago and also trying
to raise money to build a community
center on this block
called o block it's called oh block
because it's named after a young man
named od perry who was shot and killed
the gangs kept the o in his name and
start calling it o block we decided
we're gonna keep the o but we're gonna
call it opportunity block i want to
thank fox for giving me this opportunity
to bring you again rooftop revelations
every now and then i wake up with ideas
or thoughts and opinions
and i think about
people who have become
what i want to call a success story
as far as it relates to what we do at
project hood in new beginnings church
and if there ever was a person who
epitomizes uh our story of success
through struggle it's this sister who's
right here with me today
i'm so excited to have her with me tanya
is here thank you for being here tanya i
know it's cold it's okay
i want to jump right in and
tell your journey and tell your story
um
you've been such a blessing to
everything that we do
and you've been a strong part of
everything that we do
um you're a successful nurse now but
that's not
the story how it you know that's
more to the story than that um
your husband was tragically
shot and killed
uh about how many years ago it'll be 15
years september 15 years ago september
can you tell us about that experience
and tell us what happened
on september 2nd 2007 i was at church
and got a call telling me to come to a r
league's funeral home
when i got to the funeral home i noticed
polices and everyone everywhere and to
find out that my husband was shot and
killed in his vehicle yeah and and you
know i know the story how many times was
he shot he was shot on that day he was
shot like seven times seven times
and
you know he was shot and killed by a
group of guys who we later found out uh
were part of a crew who had been robbing
people and killing people all over
chicago and they've since been convicted
and in federal prison now but
one to add insult to injury not only was
he shot and killed
but
that left you with five
little girls and i want to talk about
that because
you have been
so strong
and such a good parent
tell us about the experience of having
to raise five girls when their father
has been shot and killed
it wasn't easy
i had five daughters who was left
fatherless
i'm very strong woman and i always
wanted to set a goal for my children
so
i kept
praying that was number one
because um just think about raising five
daughters with no father in chicago in
chicago the south side of chicago
so
they all you know
one got an attitude this day one acting
up that week the next week another one
acting up it was plenty of times i had
to leave work to go up to the school
because my daughter was acting out in
anger
and i had to leave work i get to the
school
she was in so much pain because of the
death of her father so she reacted out
in anger
so with the help of
new beginners church pastor brooks
project hood
i had to get a little counseling
for my kids and myself
and i always told myself was i'm what i
won't give up i couldn't give up because
i have five young ladies watching me
they need an example and
so not only were you
here it is your husband's been shot and
killed
you got these five girls
you're working a a full-time job
having to do everything
that a parent has to do for five girls
but you found time and this is what
really is amazing
you found time to go back to school
why did you go back to school i mean
because you could have just worked your
job took care of your five girls
why did you go back to school i went
back to school because i had a goal
and my goal was always i wanted to be a
nurse so i had to set examples to my fat
daughters no matter what you're going
through in life you can always be
whatever it is you choose to be
nothing can stop you if that's what your
mind is said to
so one day i just said you know what i'm
gonna go back to school
and thank god that i was able to go to
school during the hours that my kids was
in school and still work my job made it
possible for me to be able to leave work
start working different hours so i can
finish my career
i had to be the example because my
daughter didn't have the father example
of a man so i had to step up and be that
power example of a woman
and to encourage my daughters that
nothing
don't allow nothing or anything stop you
so i went back to school
while they was in school
i got my associate's degree first
still while my kids in school still was
working i went back to school and got my
bachelor's in nursing
still while my kids was in school
to my youngest graduating from
they all graduated from high school on
time thank god of that
no teen parents
thank god they didn't come a statistic
to the streets because of all the
violence in chicago because of a strong
woman and mother and determination that
i had to set a goal for my daughters
and you have done it an excellent job
and that's the reason why it's so
important that we have
um project good we want to give
women like tanya who
are going through situations
uh opportunities give them
chances allow them the help that they
need to go back to school
to
find another career to go down another
path to be successful and that's about
what we're trying to do we want
project hood to be an example so that we
can have more sisters like tanya in
chicago and we can make it a much better
place so i want to thank her i want to
salute you i want to congratulate you
working hard finishing school taking
care of your girls we love you and all
that you do
and um
now you can help us finish mentoring
these young ladies and that's really
what your gift is and i'm looking
forward to that i'm looking forward as
well all right as i always say
thank you for tuning in to our rooftop
revelations thank you to fox for giving
us this opportunity please do not forget
it is so important it is so important
that you give toward this effort it's so
important whether it's a one-time gift a
monthly gift
or a small gift or a very large gift we
need this center to be built on the
south side of chicago so we can do all
the fantastic work that we're trying to
do until tomorrow
as i always say
peace
you